well the claim that uh you know doing
the chemical castration drugs or surgery
or hormonal intervention the claim that
this prevents suicide or has a positive
psychological effects down the line is
utterly totally baseless there are no
credible long-term studies that bear
that out and one of the reasons for that
is that there couldn't possibly be any
credible long-term studies because we've
never done this to kids on this scale
ever before in history so this current
uh shall we say crop of children they
are the guinea pigs this is this is all
experimental we're sort of trying it out
on them to see if it works